our next speaker is Dennis Darby dennis
is professor emeritus in the department
of ocean earth and atmospheric sciences
at Old Dominion University and he's well
known for his important insights into
paleoclimate and paleo oceanography of
the Arctic and subarctic and in
particular long-term changes in sea ice
and the title of Dennis's talk today is
what precise source tells us about
arctic sea ice thanks thank you Mary Lou
it's a pleasure to be here and today I'm
going to walk you through some aspects
of sea ice and what we've been able to
learn about sea ice from tracing its
source where where it forms we do this
by the small amount of sea ice in the
Arctic that has sediment in it and the
first before I begin I have to admit
that I don't do this work in a vacuum
and there's a lot of people I need to
thank including my own graduate students
at Old Dominion and of course my funding
sources so I'm going to walk you through
different types of sea ice and off the
bow of US Coast Guard Cutter Healy our
largest icebreaker you what you see here
is very smooth flat ice this is what's
referred to as first year ice it's
usually no more than a meter or so thick
and and there's a general absence of
pressure ridges and then what you see it
from an aerial view from a helicopter
you see that expensive flat areas first
year I suck it's a lot easier to break
its weaker ice than than multi-year ice
and here we see is a picture of some
multi-year ice and the first thing you
notice in here is there's these pressure
ridges running through you can see them
all through the ice here and
interspersed or some smoother ice
there's probably ice that's formed in
the open leads as this ice moves apart
and comes back together the other thing
I brought to draw your attention to is
the fact that this ice has sedimented it
only about five or ten percent of the
Arctic sea ice
contain sediment like this but look at
how extensive this is if you look off in
the distance here you can see that dirty
ice extending often a distance and and
in two expeditions in 2005 the hot
tracks expedition and also in 2007 with
the Swedish expedition we ran into three
different locations in the Arctic where
we were seeing this kind of dirty ice
for three to five days straight 24 hour
days of staining and covering somewhere
around 300 kilometers extent so dirty
ice can be very extensive in local areas
and patches and we'll talk a little bit
about that later the other thing that I
wanted to show you is how large sum of
these pressure ridges occur pressure
ridges or when ice is comes back
together again it splits apart and you
have open leads in when it comes back
together again it piles up you can get
pressure ridges that are too generally
speaking today we only see them about
one or two meters and height but for
every one or two meters up above the the
ice it extends down several meters below
so you can run into very thick ice in
the Arctic and and you're driving a nice
breaker you don't want to run into too
many of these pressure ridges because
you can really slow you down now this is
today and if you go back to the first
time I was ever in the Arctic in 71 you
can see pressure ridges in the back that
are much larger they look more like what
you see here that are upwards to four or
five meters in height and this is a
rarity today very large pressure ridges
so that's a quick run through of
different types of ice scenarios in the
Arctic now I'm going to talk a little
bit about circulation because
circulation plays a big role in ice
movement as well as the winds but the
winds dominate but we still have to talk
about circulation and this is a map of
the Arctic and and what we see here is
some some of the shelf circulation and
deeper offshore first we see the Alaskan
coastal current that comes up from the
Bering Strait
and that comes around Cape Point Barrow
and it has other branches that go off
even in to harold Canyon and then we
have this East Siberian coastal current
that comes along in that direction and
we have a longshore drift along Alaska
that's a real shallow and and then we
have deeper circulation and I'll talk a
little bit about this this is the
Atlantic water that comes in off of the
North Atlantic and and in it it's warm
salty water but it sinks below the cold
fresh water in the Arctic and and it it
resides around two to six hundred meters
down and it comes around the edge of the
shelf all the way around and even on
some of the major ridges this is the the
Lomonosov Ridge here that splits the
Arctic into to the Eurasian and a
marriage in sides and we'll talk a
little bit about that and then you have
this Beaufort counter current or
undercurrent that comes along like that
so you get a very complex mixture of
currents in the the Alaskan area and I
wanted to talk about that because one of
the areas are one of the sediment
archives that will be talking about is
this core jpc 16 that has taken right on
the the flank of the barrel canyon at
1,300 meters water depth and it has
extremely high rates of sedimentation
this was the probably the longest piston
core that was ever collected in the
Arctic it's 20 meters long and the
bottom of the core is only 9,000 years
old that means that it has a
sedimentation rate of about two and a
half meters it's almost as tall as I am
every thousand years which is phenomenal
for sediment records in New York or
anywhere for that matter so that is a
very complex story about how why it has
such high sedimentation rates a lot of
it has to do with these turbidity
currents that go down the canyon form
Eddie's in the canyon and then the
fine-grained sediment comes up on the
flanks and deposits there on a routine
basis it's not that fine-grained
sediment that we're interested in all
that does is gives us bulk
we're really interested in is the sea
ice that comes around and melts and
drops sand and other particles down into
that sediment and that only makes up
about one or two percent of the sediment
but it gives us a fantastic record as
we'll see you later so I'm going to
first show you some work of the Arctic
buoy to show you the dynamics of sea ice
transport and what you're seeing here is
the these black dots are buoys or
transporters that are put out on the ice
and then are tracked over several months
until they stop working and so what
you'll see is that you'll see a series
of black dots the first black dog here
is where they drop the buoy then that's
about every month or so and then that's
the red dot is the current location in
September 1979 and so what we're going
to show you is a record going every
about every two months or so from 79 to
2002 and you just watch these we're also
going to see the shrinking and expanding
of the thickness of the ice the thickest
parts of the ice is the white part here
and it as it gets darker blue it gets
thinner and thinner until you get open
water which is actually almost navy blue
here so what you'll see here is you're
going to see a general circulation of
the Beaufort gyre which is a anti
cyclonic circulation here driven by a
high pressure system and the Beaufort
Sea and then you're going to see another
circulation planet called the trans
polar drift which comes out of Siberia
here around the laptop see and then
swings across nearly lohman officer
Ridge not through Fram Strait so let me
start this video and and one of the
things I want you to watch is don't get
confused by the shrinking and expanding
that happens the every every season but
also just watch how a regular some of
these buoys are moving they basically
seem to be just going randomly sometimes
so now you can see you're you're now in
1984-85 87-88
we've had some different years but if
you see in the Beaufort gyre things get
and you'll see new buoys appearing and
disappearing as time goes on you can
download this video off of the web it's
under the Arctic buuck program that
Ignatius rigger produced and and what I
wanted to show you that is to show you
that there's a lot of dynamic movement
in the end the sea ice it doesn't just
follow these big patterns which we are
going to show you on a map but it has a
lot of random motion and you have to
understand that this is a monthly
average if you looked at daily movements
it's even more erratic okay so the next
thing I'm going to do is talk a little
about I have to introduce the Arctic and
North Atlantic Oscillation these are
atmospherically driven phenomena is it
occur in the Arctic because they have a
lot to do with especially the Arctic
Oscillation with the ice drift and the
arctic ocean itself but the North
Atlantic and Arctic Oscillation are two
different phenomena that are highly
correlated with one another so they're
they're actually measured they have a
somewhat similar point of measurement
they picked the point in the Barrow I
mean in the Beaufort Sea and a point
near Iceland and a point near the Azores
the Arctic Oscillation is defined by the
pressure difference between the Arctic
high pressure or pressure system and
that near Iceland the North Atlantic by
that near Iceland and that near the
Azores so they're they're linked
together in some regards but these
whether these atmospheric phenomena do
have a an impact on on whether our daily
weather for example when we go into a
negative phase that sometimes referred
to as the cold phase we have weaker
upper-level winds that Jennifer was
talking about the jet stream this allows
for a lot of cold air from the Arctic to
escape and going into this last winter
we were pretty negative and no surprise
that although the Arctic Oscillation
doesn't control our weather always but
it does have an impact we did have a
colder than usual winter when we get
into the positive phase these upper
level winds are stronger
they're more control there's not so much
meandering in the jet stream and the
cold air is trapped in the Arctic and we
have basically a quite different weather
pattern across the Arctic across the
globe atmospheric scientists have been
arguing a long time about these
oscillations as to whether they're
really truly oscillations because they
don't see in the modern day record the
last 50 years any good cyclic patterns
those are statistical so that's I've
actually been corrected by atmospheric
scientist and they said you shouldn't
even call the Arctic Oscillation an
oscillation it's a quasi oscillation and
I think the problem is that atmospheric
scientists are looking at just the
instrumental record the last 30 to 50
years and us geologists we're looking at
records that go back thousands of years
and time has a nice filter effect and it
removes a lot of the noise in the in the
record and what we can see is something
right quite different but getting back
to its impact on circulation here we see
two extreme cases of the Arctic
Oscillation one in 1979 where we had a
very strong negative Arctic Oscillation
the Beaufort high is very strong you get
an expanded Beaufort gyre in this area
right up here very large and the
transpolar drift is pretty much
restricted to the Eurasian side of the
Arctic and then the other extreme here
is in when's that 1994 and here's a very
strong positive situation and here the
Beaufort gyre becomes very weak and
disorganized and look what happens to
the trans polar drift its wings way over
towards North America well this pattern
has shown even more pronounced here the
red is the positive phase of the Arctic
Oscillation this shows the surface drift
in the Arctic during a positive phase
yellow is the negative phase where you
have that expanded phase and and what
happens here is that during the positive
phase you can get sea ice that
originates over here in the care
se comes through via kiski straight
comes all the way over swings over
towards North America can come all the
way over here and here's where our jpc
16 is located right here can actually
deposit sediment and in that core
location whereas during a negative phase
that ice is restricted to the Asian side
and it's almost impossible for that ice
to get over to Alaska so what I'm going
to do is show you a record from that jpc
16 that shows the past changes of influx
of Kara ice grains and how we do that is
that we we use iron oxide grains because
they are garbage bag minerals for trace
elements they form an igneous and
metamorphic rocks tens of millions of
years ago they're there none of these
things a recent they're all weathered
out of eroded from host rocks and all
around the Arctic and basically what we
do is we analyze each individual sand
grain the average size of these grains
is about a tenth of a millimeter but
they range from forty five microns to
250 microns and we use an electron
microprobe and that's shown right here
we can analyze five elements at a time
we use 14 different elements and we use
that elemental composition like a
fingerprint and then we can trace each
grain back to the source areas and here
you see the source data set that we use
it took me about 15 years they could get
all these samples from probably tens and
tens of people that contributed samples
to this data set and we've clustered
some of these samples into groups
showing you major source areas but we
can trace each grain we have back to
that entire database of 38,000 grains
and match it up to a sand grain from a
particular source area with less than
two percent error so we're very
confident about our sources
and we use eight different iron minerals
and 14 elements so we have a lot of
variables to work with and here's the
record from JP c16 the bottom line here
is is well this is in years ad so here's
the modern 2000 here and here's goes
back to about close to a thousand years
before present and here's the killer
years and the bottom of the core is
about 9,000 years old and what we see
when we look at the Kara grains in this
core is anything but a uniform influx of
Kara grains there there's a lot of
fluxes fluctuations in these and the
first time we looked at this data set
and by the way our sampling interval is
about 22 years every sample was taken
every four centimeters that's about 22
years time lapse between them so we can
look at the kettle and scale with the
smallest we can you could look at annual
cycles but what we see here is that
about 2,000 years ago we had more than
four times as many iron grains coming
from the Kara Sea as we do today what
does that tell us what you have to have
a very strong positive Arctic
Oscillation and it has to be very
persistent for that to happen so if we
had a sort of what Jennifer was talking
about a climate system that was stuck in
a very positive mode or in a what we
call the warm phase it was you can get a
lot of iron grains coming over from Kara
Sea over a period of several decades and
accumulating here so what we see is if
we look back over the last thousand
years or so we see a big flux that's
this peak right here and there were
several big Peaks right before that this
is the Little Ice Age here and then
we're going back into this warmer
interval and we're seeing an influx of
more iron grains from kara sea and when
you look at climate change in the future
and start projecting we certainly have
to take this phenomena into effect and
what we did was we did time series
analysis on this we use several
different time series
the point 99 confidence level was shown
by this dash line here what we see here
is some very interesting cycles this one
is one and a half thousand years and
that corresponds to dance career cycles
that were recognized in the green and I
score and these are very important paleo
climatic cycles because we see this
dance garter screw cycle throughout the
glacial intervals and it's a temperature
fluctuation we see this thing
fluctuating in temperature and it's
right around one and a half thousand
years but the JPC 16-core showed several
other significant cycles seven hundred
years here 350 years 280 year 170 year
cycle and 100-year cycle so we have all
these very significant cycles going on
that we can decipher from this longer
record that are certainly going to have
an impact on on weather and climate in
the future so now I'm going to show you
some some things about modern CI so
we're going to jump from a Holocene
record the last nine thousand years to
modern sea ice and what we can learn
from looking at iron grains what we see
here is several photos that I took of
sea ice dirty sea ice in the Arctic and
one of the things that was really
interesting about this dirty sea ice was
its extent we were seeing this dirty sea
ice as I said over three to four days of
steaming normally we're covering about
80 nautical miles in a day so that's a
large area that we're seeing consistent
dirty ice and in fact during the Swedish
expedition they worked their things a
little differently I was not the chief
scientist I you had to go to the
sweeties polar Secretariat that was on
board to get permission to use the
helicopter and I was when I was running
into all this dirty ice I wanted to get
out and sample it so I needed a
helicopter because they weren't going to
stop the ship for me and and after about
three days of pestering this guy for the
helicopter which is expensive I
understand he
started hiding from me I had a sort of
syrtis find him he was located somewhere
high hidden on the ship so I he wouldn't
give me permission but anyway when you
get out on the ice you we found really
thick accumulations of a vice and we
thought this was direct evidence of
anchor ice anchor ice forms in less than
50 meters around the coastal areas where
ice actually starts to form on the
bottom attached to the bottom and gets
thicker and thicker until it gets thick
enough that is buoyant enough to lift
off when it does it takes all kind of
sediment with it whatever is on the
bottom most of the Arctic shelves are
pretty fine grain but you do get its and
that comes up with that and you get
seashells like this right here and even
see we did we found and that we found
this out in the middle of the Arctic
Ocean we were thousands of kilometers
from land okay and here's a melt pawn
that you can see how some of that can
get concentrated but the other way in
which sediment gets in the ice is what's
called suspension freezing and this is
in open water you requires open water
and you have to have wave activity and
you get circulation patterns that
supercooled water gets close to the bar
of ice crystals can form and the
sediment gets stirred up and the ice
crystals actually float the sediment to
the surface once that's that ice gets to
the surface it formed slush ice which
then forms pancake ice and that shuts
down the process because then it shuts
down the waves it shuts down the
circulation and it's self limiting so
suspension freezing can be a very
important process but it doesn't give
you high concentrations of sediment it
gives you very low concentrations to
sediment and we were seeing high
concentrations and there was a bias
involved here because when you're up on
the on the bridge of a icebreaker and
you're looking for dirty ice you're not
going to see something that's a few
milligrams per liter you're going to see
something that's kilograms per liter and
so more likely than not you're going to
stop the ship or so go sample anchor ice
deposits and when we did this we found
something fascinating and it was really
puzzling at first
two-thirds of the samples we had looked
like this there was one source and one
source only that was significant and
this one here but we sound at least a
third of the samples contain one source
and this was from North America and
here's a source from Russia when sea ice
and train set of it it's going to
entrain it from one locality not to it's
a self-limiting process though even with
anchor ice when it lifts off it just has
the sediment from once upon sight so how
are we seeing sources from two different
disparaging areas there are thousands of
kilometers apart and the answer for that
is when these ice floes mingle there's a
lot of dynamic separation of the ice and
coming back together again it's like a
jigsaw puzzle out there and a good
friend of mine dawn pair of it showed me
a slide I was trying to get it from him
and I ran out of time but he showed me a
melt pond with a sharp line right down
through but one side of it was dirty ice
and the other one was clean and it was
just a sharp demarcation and that was
where ice had separated broke apart and
came back together again then come back
together him where it was it came back
together for different ice so you can
get mixing of ice quite frequently and
that's what we're seeing out here so now
I'm going to take you back into the past
again and we're going to look at a
fascinating core this is the a sec score
a sec stands for the Arctic coring
expedition this is the first and only
time that the ocean drilling program
took a drilling rig into the Arctic it
was a very expensive proposition
required a Russian nuclear icebreaker
and a regular ice breaker of the Odin
just to keep this platform in place
because sea ice is moving all the time
and they have to be able to stay put for
days on end without moving and they were
able to drill several drill holes and
composite it down to about 400 meters
depth it gave us a fantastic record of
the past 50 million years of
sedimentation in the Arctic i'm going to
show you that story in a second and then
i'm going to jump over here too
I am straight and show you a much
shorter record that goes back only about
40,000 years and this is that polar
Stern boxscore 1230 so first the a sec
score and this is what we're looking at
here is the maximum number of grains
from any one source from all around the
Arctic that was the maximum number of
grains from any one source okay and and
these sources have to be more than one
year ice drift from a sex from the core
site and we did this with a very
conservative approach we said well we
don't know what the circulation was like
40 30 even 20 million years ago in the
Arctic you can only assume maybe it was
similar to the Beaufort gyre and the
transporter drift but you can't can't be
certain so we and you also can't be
certain about the ice drift today the
average drift of ice is about three
centimeters a second and now it varies
quite a bit depending on location near
Fram Strait it could be 12 centimeters
per second but in other places could be
much less and not only that but the ice
can reverse directions a lot and so it
goes backwards so we said okay forget
about that we're going to just say that
it's moving five or six centimeters per
second and instead of it following the
circulus tracks does today we're going
to say it just starts at the shelf and
goes straight towards a sex without
deviating dozen reverse doesn't jiggle
around at all so we're only looking at
sites that were far enough away from a
sex that it would take more than a year
because if it takes more than a year the
ice has to summer over has to be there
in the summer that means its perennial
so what we're looking at here is a
record of perennial ice and other words
ice that exists in the Arctic year-round
and what we see here is a fascinating
record going back to about 50 million
years we see no ice ice rafting at all
these are samples that are just devoid
of iron grains and then we get up here
and we see this big jump and that jump
occurs at about 44 or 47 million years
depending on which age model you use I
want to get into details
there's one aged model here is the old
one this is the newer age model that's
been proposed a very similar except when
this area and and what happened here was
really interesting to us because the
perennial ice conditions didn't last
long each sample there's about 70,000
years in it you know so we didn't get a
very close sampling like we did in JP
c16 a sex had a lot of demand for
samples there was thousands of people
trying to get samples so we only got
samples spaced out about every 50
centimeters but even with that record we
could see that it didn't last for more
than a hundred thousand years for sure
and probably a lot less than that we
went back to seasonal ice and then it
came back again several times in this
whole period between 44 million years
and about 37 million years is a period
of unstable conditions in the Arctic now
you have to remember that the Arctic
reached its maximum actually the earth
reached its one of its maximum
temperatures about 50 million years ago
and and and and now we're just six
million years later we're seeing
perennial ice in the Arctic and and it's
fluctuating back and forth until you get
to about 37 million years ago and then
we have pretty much continuous perennial
ice the interesting thing here is that
the ice sheets on Antarctica didn't
start to about 34 36 million years ago
so that means that there was perennial
ice in the Arctic before major ice
sheets started to develop in Antarctica
and we're also seeing that Greenland may
in fact have had ice on it much earlier
than we thought today and that's another
subject that we're working on today but
that's that indicates to us that perhaps
the Arctic instead of just responding to
temperature change and global climate
the Arctic may in fact have played a
role in changing climate and because we
know that once you have print ice up
there you have ice in the summer
reflects as Jennifer showed us a lot of
the solar radiation and it can cool the
globe down significantly now we don't
see it returning to seasonal ice until
this crisis called the
city in crisis and for those who are not
paleo climatologists this is when the
mediterranean sea dried up that's about
six million years ago and for some
reason circulation changed and we went
back to seasonal ice for extended period
of time then went back to perennial and
then in the last one and a half million
years we get into the ice age when we
had ice sheets developing and
disappearing and we had a really large
fluctuations in climate and here we see
a seasonal ice returning several times
during the Pleistocene the last million
and a half years so that's the a sex
story and here's the Fram Strait story
and now you're looking at a much more
recent record it goes back to maybe
fifty thousand years or forty thousand
years at most these are thousands of
years excuse me over here is thousands
of years I have a hard time even reading
mine it's about 30,000 years so we're
looking at the last thirty thirty-five
thousand years and and this is the ice
iron grains that have been traced back
to the banks island area and we know
that that's where major tongues of the
ice sheet in northern Canada flowed into
the Arctic Ocean and then there was a
lesser ice sheet called nu ition that
covered the Canadian islands of the
archipelago and that ice sheet also
capped off icebergs and and lo and
behold we could look at different events
here where ice rafting of large amounts
of ice rafted too bright to try this was
making it through Fram Strait at almost
identical times as there was large
armadas of icebergs coming out of Hudson
Strait in Canada flowing down through
the Labrador sea and out into the North
Atlantic all the way over to England and
depositing sediment all the way across
the North Atlantic and these things are
almost identical in timing to those
Heinrich events in the North Atlantic
and we can see them so not only was
there a North Atlantic event but there
was an Arctic event that coincided is
just as well going back at least to
Heinrich event for
okay I'm going to finish up now with a
little story about the Greenland ice
sheet because that's been in the news a
lot we we have been startled by the
rapid disappearance of ice in Greenland
and the question comes up is is the ice
grafting or ice calving off of Greenland
been a uniform factor of just increasing
in the last few decades or is there been
cyclic fluctuations so here we see the
green shows us the pattern of ice ref
did you try this that's been traced back
to the east greenland ice and that's
where most of the big icebergs come from
the one that sank the titanic came from
that area probably and we see anything
but i could a uniform calving rate over
what this goes back to what 1890 or
something like that so the 1800s is last
120 years or so of a record so every
decade or two we see an increase in nice
rafting and we can say that see a
similar thing with our iron grains from
a core off of South Greenland and here
we see I can trace back to individual
parts of the Greenland ice sheet the red
here is South Greenland and the black is
East Greenland they're pretty much in
synchronous there's a little bit of lag
and lead to each one but that's minor
and what we see here is a 15 to 30 year
cycle more or less we don't have a long
enough record and we're working on a
much longer record that will be
publishing later on and we'll do time
series analysis on it to see so the the
take-home story here is that the
Greenland ice sheet is anything but a
continuous process of calving it's very
cyclic so these cycles are imposed upon
modern global warming and now that means
that when we get to a peak in one of our
cycles and and we have global warming
going on we're going to see probably
maybe an enhanced
diminishing of the Greenland sea ice and
of course this has major implications on
sea level especially the folks like
myself that my house is 17 feet above
sea level i live in virginia beach and
it's we're the second most vulnerable
area in the united states when it comes
to sea level change New Orleans is the
first so we're right behind New Orleans
as far as being vulnerable to sea level
change so it's a big concern to us and
now I'm going to leave you with a
picture of pancake ice and I don't know
how many people how many people in here
have ever seen pancake ice okay just a
few so here's here's a shot of pancake
ice that's what it looks like and I want
to thank you